I typically make a coffee concentrate for my coffee
animals and came across information on cold brewing,
which might be a more convenient way
to make the concentrate.
Then I read some information on your website
about essentially a cold brew process
for concentrate.
Is this still something you would recommend?
Yes, absolutely.
Because if you're going to make enough coffee
and a concentrate for the week, yes, you could do it that way.
Information I was reading online about cold brewing in general
says that it increases the caffeine content
and decreases the acid.
So would the lower acid content make the cold brewing option
less attractive?
No, it's the caffeine that makes it attractive.
So that is why you're using the coffee
and a coffee for doing coffee animals.
It's very, very light roast.
You wouldn't, I don't know if anybody's ever tried drinking
the coffee and a coffee, but it's horrible tasting.
You wouldn't want to drink it.
It's super, super high capy to taste horrible.
Excuse me.
So the reason why it is so lightly roasted
is because you want the higher capy content.
So that makes it more attractive for coffee animals.
So this is just fine to do it this way.